okay so Ant-Man and the WASP quantumania
is now out to own digital e and after
we're watching the movie I thought I'd
do a breakdown of the insane details in
the film that I haven't seen in other
videos this isn't gonna be a scene by
scene thing but rather it'll cover the
most in-depth ones and go over how they
connect to the MCU and the greater
Marvel Universe thank you Spiderman now
one of the coolest scenes in the film
involves Scott traveling into a
probability storm on a subatomic level
down here we see as he creates multiple
variants depending on what choices that
he makes huge it adds to Canadian lab
for pointing out that a really cool way
to start this notion is the fact that
when Scott takes a step a version of M
pops out behind him him taking a step
forward is him making a choice unless
there's an alternate version of him that
didn't end up doing this however things
go away Beyond this and it actually ties
nicely in with the previous Ant-Man and
the WASP film in that we learn that the
character girls had ties to the quantum
realm and after seeing this film it's
pretty obvious that she was tied in with
some kind of probability storm there's a
brilliant moment in the trailer that
discusses the quantum realm and during
it it also shows how ghost's abilities
work you open up the quantum Realm
that's when his crazy could be gold so
like walks through walls
stole your Tech
if you look closely at this moment of
her walking through the door you can see
that another version of her pops out the
back and this looks similar to how one
appears from Scott this is a version of
her that opened the door whereas the
main one we have doesn't unless it's
showing the two possible outcomes like
what we get with Scott now this is also
a domain in which reality itself is
formed and it's at this subatomic level
that branching timelines are created
particles coexist
in a stable phase relationship if the
system is interfered with that stability
becomes chaos in other words the object
in question would be both in and out of
phase with multiple parallel realities
dealing with reality also means that we
get certain rules and we see a giant
version of Ant-Man turning into ribbons
at one point this is a similar effect to
what happened with Reed Richards and
Multiverse of Madness and this was
because Wanda's powers are tied in with
reality now upon approaching the Rings
we also see that they have strange
markings and glyphs on them they look
extremely similar the ones that appeared
in the eternals and as we know they were
created by the celestials the celestials
also created the universe as well and
it's possible that these markings and
glyphs are actually tied indirectly with
them I've recently gone back to both
Blade Runner movies for the channel and
all the Nexus 6 replicants in that have
serial numbers on them at a subatomic
level I love it if we discover that this
was something similar here with
celestials placing markings and codes on
things further down you get as a sign of
their craftsmanship eventually Scott is
saved by hope and behind her we can see
multiple versions all coming in
eventually these Scott go back into the
original and this is symbolic because it
shows the only goal I have at this point
had they stayed apart and there would
have been conflict in them but them all
coming together at one cements are the
only choice hope wants to make is to
save Scott Scott comes together because
all he wants to do is save his daughter
and this beats the variants that were
caused by this storm and this
probability storm also explains why Kang
didn't Venture down there the last thing
he wants to do is create more variants
as this will in turn create more
versions of him that he has to fight off
against currently end of the movie we do
meet the Council of kangs and this is
the scene that's ripped right out of
their first appearance that was in
Avengers 2 6 7 and the giant crowd shot
includes some of the alien variants that
popped up in that panel however at the
center of it all is Roma turt what I
believe is the Scarlet Centurion and
also their leader who's known as a
mortis in the comics this is the oldest
version of Nathaniel Richards and at
some point all the kangs eventually turn
into him ramatar is one of the first
versions of the character and he
actually travel back in time to ancient
Egypt in order to become a great Pharaoh
a huge announcing Iraq stars are
pointing out that Moonlight actually had
an Easter egg related to him and it's
clear that all these versions have had
something to do with the MCU at some
point and we learned that the Kang we
meet in this movie is actually known as
the Exile and it's possible that we've
had enough Tom in the MCU already around
the arena we can catch three statues and
we know that in he who remains castle
and Loki that there were some there too
these were of the three time Keepers
which could represent the three members
of the Council of kangs there was a
vault statue there as well but we
couldn't tell who this was because it
was smashed up big few times
but it's possible that this was actually
the exiled Kang hence why it was broken
up into several pieces this could also
cement the fact that he remains is
actually an elderly version of the Exile
who we end up meeting throughout this
movie the three main kangs probably
built the Great Castle as a place to
look over the timelines and then I think
he who remains one destroyed only the
timelines and then took over this
location as a place to watch over
everything this is why there's that
destroyed statue but just the one
version of Kang remaining instead of
three now their goals are also the same
too with the Exiles saying that he wants
to destroy almost all of the timelines
so he can stop all of the incursions he
says the Multiverse is being destroyed
because of the chaos caused by them
unless he wants to put an end to the
destruction that they bring I saw their
chaos
spreading across realities I saw the
Multiverse
and it was dying
time all because of them
however it's also important to bear in
mind that Kang also wants to be a
conqueror that rules overall now before
he was canceled Jonathan Mages actually
talked about basing this version of
kangan Alexander the Great who much like
him built his own Dynasty known as the
archaea Dynasty his realm was so big
that the Sun never set on it it's said
that when Alexander saw the breadth of
his domain that he wept because there
were no more worlds left to conquer and
I could actually see this being the case
with he who remains too he seems like a
bored man who spends his time sitting
around in his castle because he's at a
point where he has nothing left to do
it's very similar to how we found Thanos
in endgame and they may potentially
bring this across to the MCU as well now
when he who remains was telling the
story about all his variants we actually
saw him demonstrating the Multiverse by
having timelines on top of timelines
this is brought across later on when
Kang's explaining occasions to Janet and
they may have used a similar explanation
method to show their one in the same we
can also catch Kang standing in the
center of a ring and this Echoes he
remains telling his origin story in
which he stood inside one as well
although Kang is seen as the bad guy
he's very much just doing the thing that
we know he who remains accomplished and
Marvel painting him out as a hero is
actually hinted to us in the logo as
always the Marvel Studios intro is back
and every single version of this only
ever has heroes in it that seems to be
the case here too with shuri now being
added in it along with he who remains
now a nice design detail can be seen in
Kang's chair and just like how the
timelines are shown by he who remains we
can see his chairs designers as circular
ring around the outside of it with a
circular chair in the middle similar how
the center of the universe is depicted
time being a ring is also very important
as well as it shows that it all loops
around so the things with he who remains
in Kang will continue to happen because
they are relying on each other to happen
in order to happen lots of timey why me
wibbly wobbly stuff and all of Kang's
Tech deals with circles which we see
throughout the movie later on we catch
his soldiers working on their monitors
and all of the overlays have circles on
them when we get a proper look at
chronopolis we can also see circles
exist in all the infrastructure showing
how much the shape is influenced Kang
now earlier we talked about Reed
Richards and Kang is actually thought to
be one of his descendants they seem to
confirm this is the case in the MCU as
well as the versions that come in warp
using the same portal Tech to what he
had in the Multiverse of Madness when
they come in you might also notice
there's a guy in the right standing in
his suit it's possible that this is
actually Mr Griffin who we've already
had an odd to in Loki season 1. at one
point Kang came in masquerading as a
businessman named Griffin who claimed to
be the CEO of King Industries we've
already seen the name King before and it
could be spotted on The Avengers Tower
as we move through the void that episode
also showed us Yellow Jackets helmet and
as we learn in this film he was scooped
up by Kang to become Modoc don't show
the bot mate do not show the but
anyway as we know the void is where he
who remains cast things off and it's
possible that he threw the armor down
there at some point now if you're
enjoying the video so far we'd massively
appreciate the Thumbs Up Button as it
helps us in the algorithm and it also
lets us know you'd prefer to watch this
over the other we put out looking at you
what a ship down and then explained dear
me now you can also support us by
picking a bar Ant-Man Size Matters
t-shirt or a shop Zero edition it sells
lots of merch that goes directly the
channel and it basically helps videos
like this get made it's linked us to top
comment and we'll move on to that
because I'll stop spamming you now the
movie opens with Janet discovering Kang
who's crash landed in the quantum realm
from here we could discuss in San
Francisco which is also where a lot of
chongqi ended up taking place might even
be this this bus that he had a fight on
me it's not but uh both films feature
beacons and the rings around Kang's
chair also resemble the 10 Rings now
over the top of this we can hear the
theme from the sitcom welcome back
codder and this is actually playing off
the back of the last movie in which we
had come on get Happy by David Cassidy
this was used for The Partridge Family
and thus we have this sitcom idea later
on both films although these aren't
insane details the reason I'm bringing
them up is because of how they play into
the ending we get a similar scene to
this with Scott walking down the street
now we can hear that the song is used
again everything seems like it's okay
but the production team actually do some
really subtle things to hammer home the
idea that Kang's slowly seeping his way
into Scott's mind a final walk is a wash
with green now we can also catch
multiple people that are wearing purple
these are both of Kang's colors and we
can see a woman as she steps off the
payment wearing purple one with her dog
and a pram and yeah just lots of people
wearing purple and green now there's
actually a couple that walk past them at
one point and then they appear further
up the street I've seen theories that
this could show time travel or something
which I don't know about that I think
it's just a continuity error but the
constant combo of purple and green helps
to add to the paranoia now he gets Scott
meeting with Jimmy woo and he bursts
sleight of hand trick which makes a card
appear just like how Jimmy did it in one
division Jimmy Lynn sleight of hand for
that because he was obsessed with Scott
doing it in Ant-Man and the wasp and as
I've been saying it's all
how about the fact they grab dinner
actually calls back to that movie
because Jimmy said did you want to grab
dinner or something I mean because I'm
free yeah come on you also get a cameo
of my man from The Watcher YouTube
channel that should have been me it
should have been me
anyway we see Scott at Baskin and Robins
and can catch him winning an employee of
the century award we actually see his
photo and if you zoom in you might
notice that his name badge says Jack
which was the Alias he used in that
original film this is actually a little
not to Paul Rudd's real life son who he
wanted to give a shout out to in that
movie now speaking of shout outs we can
see on the back of Scott's book that
there's a quote from Bruce Banner and
also Christine Everhart you might
recognize Christine's name and she did a
big spread on Tony Stark in the first
Iron Man film well she did quite a
spread on Tony last year and she wrote a
story as well he was very impressive
that was good Everhart had fans forever
hard and sake and she also did an
exclusive interview with Scott which can
be found on YouTube and you can buy this
book in real life and it was actually
given lip service to in wakanda forever
and mention of it could be seen along
the Anderson Cooper ticker now as the
camera goes into the Bookshop we can
also see a sign outside that says the
Avengers and then blank Thanos guessing
that is said kill killed but they want
to keep it family friendly and make
Scott seem like a nice guy now though
things seem to be going good we are
reintroduced to Cassie Lang who's up in
jail we find out that she was helping at
a homeless protest and this was for
people who are evicted during the blip
this is a similar sort of thing to
Falcon in the Winter Soldier and in that
we joined the flag Smashers who'd been
left as refugees due to them being
brought back five years later this is
kind of on Scott in a way and I do like
how they stuck Cassie off in a jail cell
much like how he was introduced in that
first film this shot is also very
similar in composition to the van one
from Ant-Man and the WASP but Scots now
in Hank's seat Being the disapproving
adult he doesn't think they should be
messing around in the day-to-day stuff
it's nicely building off the back of
that because Hank was doing the same a
huge announce to I added a map for
pointing out the reason the planet might
have bounced back so quickly Kobe down
to hope we discover that she's been
using pimtech to help with deforestation
and this is also when a cross into food
production the Earth would suddenly have
over 3 billion more mouth to feed so
they need someone like this who'd help
leading the charge you might also notice
that the company is now called Pym van
dime instead of just being pimtech
because Hope's now the CEO and we see
this food production coming in full
effect come the next scene with a pizza
getting doubled in size Peyton Reed
actually said that this was a nod at the
back to the future scene from the second
film in which they did something similar
with a pizza oven now Scott of course
brought up Back to the Future in endgame
Back to the Future is a bunch of
what about they do a bit of a
deeper cut to that movie later on when
we see his daughter go big they talk
about getting Citrus Cravings I really
want like a lime right Citrus it's weird
I know and this goes back to two moments
in the MCU at the airport after the
giant man seen Scott asked if anyone had
orange slices does anyone have any
orange slices and when Hawkeye returned
from the quantum Realms Scott also
rushed over with some orange slices
which could be seen clearer during a
dilated moment that was shown in the TV
spots we can also catch a world's best
dad mug and this is a call back to the
world's greatest grandma trophy from the
previous film anyway in the quantum
realm they encounter the rebels who are
based slightly on the characters the
micro notes for the movie they've
combined elements of the Negative Zone
and microverse with them and have also
adapted cryola who appeared when Hulk
traveled to the dimension in his 156th
issue now in a nice bit of attention to
detail we can actually catch a miniature
Sun for following Cassie and Scotch just
over their shoulders which then
transforms into the big hulking guy
after making its attack with Janet and
Co we watch as he explains the quantum
realm and this actually pulls from a
deleted scene from the prior Ant-Man in
the WASP movie there are worlds here
worlds within worlds
worlds upon World entire civilizations
far more than we ever theorized
eventually Scott and Cassie are taken
before Webb who's voiced by David ass
malchin amongst his followers we can
also catch a group of people who all
have colored rockheads I have seen on
Twitter that this could actually be
remnants of the Infinity Stones because
as Thanos said he reduced them to atoms
they do still need to exist on some
level for reality to still function so
they may be down in the quantum realm
Out Of Reach of those on the surface
nice little catch a verb also asks how
many holes he has and he's sad because
he's not got any holes but at the end he
gets them yeah because it's good writing
do you understand how it's good writing
uh speaking of writing later on Hank Pym
talks about how he dated a woman called
Linda his name is actually Jeff levnes's
real life's mother's name and originally
Linda was going to be played by Jennifer
Coolidge nice segue there and as Janet
and Cole fly out we can catch a mural of
Kang on the wall showing how he rules
over this domain is then signified by
the blue glowing orbs and Rings which
are of course in line with his Tech
during the tour Janet mentions subatomic
air which is actually a solar system
from the comics that exists down in the
microbase we also see some Kang's forces
and later on quas reads their mind which
proves that they're human possible that
these are actually earlier versions of
the TBA agents who've had their memories
white so that they can function as
slaves for Kang eventually we come face
to face with him and though it's a bit
obvious that he's talking about killing
Thor saying the one with the hammer he
could even mean Jane Foster or
potentially throg hope you got out that
jar mate and in Loki throg was sentenced
to the void along with all those other
Loki variants so now everyone on Twitter
is losing it on how did this version of
Kang beat though if he's losing their
hands there are versions of Thor that
aren't as strong as the one that we know
now before that though we get Modoc
which
don't know if I can defend this uh but
if you if you look away from the
Facebook just take your eyes away from
the face you might notice that there's a
heart rate monitor in the middle of his
chest this actually ends up turning red
and flatlining at the end when he dies
which is a nice way to say goodbye to
this amazing character now learning
about Kang in his backstory is easily my
favorite scene in the film due to the
performances we see this very much feels
like it's building off the back of the
cave scene in Iron Man and we have her
working away with her Ally similar how
Tony did it back then both were trying
to escape their confines but whereas
Tony got away Janet doomed herself to
remain there to stop Kang getting out
now in flashback we see Kang wiping out
timelines and catch a man disintegrating
which appears similar how people
disappear on Loki when they hit with one
of the TVA sticks the scars on his face
also dominate his lurk and in the comics
they were giving us a way for Kang to
remember who he was and who he's
destined to be now the new origin story
Forum titled only myself left to conquer
dealt with a young Nathaniel coming
across his elevation and he did whatever
he could to stop himself from becoming
him the scars seal this fight though and
Kang's rebellious side of course leads
to the incoming war that he's trying to
avert akang also later calls Cassie
Jelly Bean which is a nickname Janna
gave to her as a child showing how close
he actually were either way it leads to
a big battle between the good guys and
Kang and we basically get a dictatorship
versus socialism metaphor yay now
there's lots of Honey I Shrunk the Kids
mirroring in here with the ants helping
our heroes to escape Modoc learns not to
be a dick and skulls he uses a giant
platform as a shield which is a call
back to his Idol Captain America they
seemly defeat the greatest threat in the
Multiverse using ants but he returns
before they can get back to the surface
now one thing I noticed is that we get a
big boot stump from Kang that had me
thinking of this and
boot Kang is kicked in the multiversal
engine but in the comics the rule is
that if you never see a body then the
character's not dead who knows if we
will see Mages again as well and at this
point of making this video there's been
no word from Marvel over what's going on
you know what I'm talking about that
controversy I don't want to get to pull
the video down because we were having
fun but yeah at the moment we don't know
what's happening we do know though that
Kang will be back and there's even a
nice little nod to him in the final few
scenes as I mentioned before purple and
green dominate the last scene and in the
restaurant we can also see his colors
return once more the balloons are big
and purple and the cake itself is bright
green now we do have Mages Victor timely
and that second post credit scene with
him being a variant I traveled back to
the dawn of the 20th century to build an
entire town around him the credits also
say Kang will return and this version
that we see here may potentially be the
one we meet in the movie masquerading is
Victor timely that's where another
timely video though and we will of
course be covering Loki's season 2 when
it releases online in the meantime
though I'd love to hear your favorite
Easter eggs that popped up in this movie
again I tried to make these ones that I
haven't seen in other videos but I'm
sure there's lots of things that I've
missed so you know it's your time to
shine baby now as a thank you for doing
that we are in a competition right now
and giving away the quantumania steel
book to three subscribers on the 15th of
May all you have to do to be on the
chance of winning is like the video make
sure you subscribe with notifications on
and drop a comment below with your
thoughts on the movie and you know what
just drop any comment and you'll be
entered now if you want something else
to watch then make sure you check out
one of our breakdowns on screen now you
want a mature movie don't you don't care
about this comic stuff so yeah go watch
up later on a breakdown on screen much
better than this video and I'll see you
over there right after this by the way
thanks for sticking to the video having
all and you take care yourself peace